HEY, DON LEMON -- NO, SHOULD I
SAY GOOD MORNING, DON LEMON.
>> I DON'T HAVE ANY IDEA WHAT
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT.
>> MAYBE YOU ARE ON LONDON TIME.
THERE IS BIG NEWS OVER HERE.
>> I'M EXHAUSTED.
I JUST GOT BACK TODAY.
WHAT A PLAN THIS BEING ON THE
PLANE WHILE THIS HAPPENED AND MY
PHONE WAS HEATED UP ALL DAY.
LET ME JUST SAY IT'S BITTERSWEET
FOR ME BECAUSE I WORK WITH THE
BEST TEAM IN THIS BUILDING, ONE
OF THE BEST TEAMS IN THIS
BUSINESS AND WE BUILT THIS SHOW
OUT OF NOTHING.
THIS SHOW WAS NOT SUPPOSED TO
EXIST.
AND BECAUSE I HAVE SUCH
FANTASTIC PRODUCERS AND WRITERS
AND MARIA WHO IS MY EXECUTIVE
PRODUCER AND MY EXECUTIVE
PRODUCER, PHILLIP, THE PEOPLE
THAT WRITE THINGS THAT COME OUT
OF MY MOUTH, THE THINGS THAT
MAKE SENSE.
SUSAN IS GREAT AND OTHER SENIOR
PRODUCER ALYSSA WELLDON.
I JUST HAVE REALLY WONDERFUL
PEOPLE WHO KNOW ME.
IT'S LIKE A MIND MELD.
BUT I WAS PRESENTED WITH AN
OPPORTUNITY THAT I CAN'T PASS UP
AT THIS NETWORK, AND WE HAVE A
NEW BOSS, WHO IS A MORNING SHOW
E EXMPREARIO.
AND HE WANTS A SHOW TO KICK OFF
THINGS EVERY DAY.
AND SAYING HE MOVED ME -- HE
ASKED ME AND I SAID YES.
I COULD HAVE SAID NO.
THIS IS MY SHOW.
I HAVE A CONTRACT FOR THIS SHOW.
I DECIDED I WOULD TAKE HIM UP ON
THAT.
THIS IS NOT SOMEONE SAYING YOU
MUST MOVE TO THE RIGHT DON LEMON
AND GIVE SO MUCH OF YOUR
PERSPECTIVE.
THAT IS NOT REAL.
THIS IS FODDER FOR TWITTER.
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY.
THIS IS A PROMOTION.
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR ME TO
CREATE SOMETHING AROUND ME AND I
GET TO WORK WITH TWO GREAT
LADIES WHO YOU KNOW, POPPY
HARLOW, WHO I HAVE KNOWN FOR
DECADES.
I KNEW HER CHILDREN AND HUSBAND.
AND KAITLYN COLLINS, SAME THING,
WE HAVE BEEN FRIENDS SINCE
KAITLYN HAS BEEN AT THE NETWORK.
IT'S REALLY GREAT.
THE ONLY THING IS THE BOSS LAUGH
AND SAID I'M GOING TO HAVE TO
PUT SOME EXTRA MONEY IN THE
BUDGET TO HAVE SOMEONE COME OUT
TO YOUR HOUSE AND WAKE YOU UP
EVERY MORNING.
SINCE I HAVE BEEN IN THIS
BUSINESS SINCE THE 1990s,
SERIOUSLY, I HAVE ONLY BEEN ON
THE NIGHT SHIFT.
THE ONLY TIME I WAS ON THE
MORNING SHIFT WAS A FILL IN,
WHEN I WAS FILLING IN ON THE
TODAY SHOW OR WEEKEND TODAY OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT, EVEN ON THE
MORNING SHOW HERE.
THAT IS THE ONLY TIME I HAVE
EVER -- THAT HASN'T BEEN THAT
MUCH, SO IT'S GOING TO TAKE SOME
GETTING USED TO.
>> I TELL YOU, I KNOW TWO
THINGS.
NOBODY PUTS BABY IN THE CORNER
AND NOBODY DICTATES ANYTHING TO
DON LEMON.
>> THANK YOU.
>> I WAIT UP AND STAY UP EVERY
NIGHT FOR DON LEMON, I'M HAPPY
TO GET UP IN THE MORNING.
I CAN'T WAIT.
>> THANK YOU.
WHEN I STARTED DOING THIS, IT
WAS EIGHT AND A HALF YEARS AGO
AND THEY WERE DOING PILOT --
WHAT ARE WE GOING TO DO WITH
PRIME TIME?
AND OUR OLD BOSS SAID GO DO IT.
AND IT WAS THE ONLY -- HE SAID
THE ONLY PILOT THAT MATTERS IS
THE ONE ON THE AIR.
SO YOU GO AT IT.
AND THEN IT BECAME CNN TONIGHT
AND THEN CNN TONIGHT WITH DON
LEMON AND THEN DON LEMON
TONIGHT.
I'M HAPPY IT IS A SUCCESSFUL
SHOW.
IT HAS BEEN 8 AND A HALF YEARS.
I WANT TO TRY SOMETHING ELSE.
WHAT IS LIFE WITHOUT RISKS.
>> I'M SO EXCITED FOR YOU.
WE ARE ALL BEHIND YOU.
IT WILL BE WONDERFUL FOR YOU.
YOU, KAITLYN AND POPPY.
I AM TELLING YOU, THOUGH, WE
HAVE ALL BEEN WATCHING YOU ON --
IN ENGLAND TIME, YOU ARE GOOD IN
THE MORNING, KID.
>> OH, THANK YOU, YOUNG LADY.
THE NAME OF THE SHOW WILL BE DO
AND K POP.
>> I WILL NEED ONE MORE FOCUS
GROUP, JUST ONE.
TAKE CARE.
>> YOU ARE THE BEST.
SEE YOU TOMORROW.
>> TAKE CARE.